okay I told it Evan I would do the intro
because I have a song but I don't really
have one
so I'm gonna make it up go for it this
podcast is the Evan Caitlyn pod where we
talking about things hi guys welcome to
another evident Caitlyn podcast let's
just jump into things today is going to
be a Q&A episode a patreon Q&A yeah so
thank you everyone over there for your
support but first we're gonna talk about
what's new what's new Caitlyn haha we've
just kind of been here at home not
leaving much you know what we have been
doing a lot though she's kind of like
leaving but just in a digital way
hanging out hundreds of our of our
friends yeah we've been streaming a lot
more like a lot a lot more and it's been
really fun and one thing that we've done
two times since we last recorded a
podcast is to charity streams and I
remember this because our last podcast
we were like oh
our charity stream is tomorrow how's it
gonna go oh yeah you know so we've done
to now which is pretty crazy and they
went really well
yeah the first so nervous her so nervous
the first one raised four thousand seven
hundred dollars the second one raised
seven thousand four hundred dollars
which is super super cool really proud
of our community coming together set up
over 12,000 in total in a couple weeks
yeah across these two streams all of our
pandemic relief all of the funds going
straight to charities that can really
make a difference buying masks buying
food for people who need it you know in
general we do still have the second one
open on Twitch so if you're like I want
to do some good like we're not doing
another big charity stream but we're
just keeping it open hmm but it was
nerve-wracking cuz you know typically
our streams we stream for like two and a
half to three and a half hours yeah it's
kind of our average that's kind of like
like I'm not sure if we've talked about
this yet but Caitlyn and I defined
introverts and extroverts by like do we
get energy up by being around other
people
or do we get energy out by being alone
and being alone would be introverts and
being around other people to get your
energy up extroverts and I think that by
that definition we are both definitely
introverts we get our energy up when
we're in like chill time and then we can
spend that energy yeah I think so I was
gonna recharge recharge alone and we're
getting so pumped naari recharge our
batteries yeah and so typically after
like a few hours of being like very
social we're like a little break it's
kind of you know like get to our
computers and do some quiet computer
productive but doing a with our first
stream with seven hours in the second
one was eight hours now that's a
marathon that's a marathon like don't
get me wrong
it was super fun it was like it's kind
of like when we've gone to events and
it's just like so much concentrated
goodness but then you're so exhausted
afterwards because it's like a lot more
than you're used to
well we also host ourselves in other way
is because we didn't want the streams to
be like just one thing so in the second
stream Caitlin did art live taking
requests drawing is she you know we
played internet games like like Google
feud and everything and we like I think
that that pushing ourselves like for a
good cause like this also have the side
effect of allowing us to grow and get
more confident in foot streaming in
general that's cool yeah I would totally
do more requests drawings like colored
versions yeah may wishes do like an art
stream where Caitlin just draws art all
stream and I like me and chat and there
we just hang out and watch Caitlin draw
this it's fun and you can like read
people's cuz I couldn't read people's
comments when I was drawing people had
feedback I had to like take a break to
look so you can like give me suggestions
like a b-dry if that'd be so fun I want
to do that yeah okay maybe if we like
to keep streaming but we don't want to
overload our editors like we want to
give them more ketchup we'll start
incorporating those they won't be edited
highlights dreams yeah and then after
the stream we'll post all of your you
can do it in layers this time and then
you can post all the Photoshop files so
people can be fun yeah it was it was a
good a really good experience doing the
charity stream yes then it just you know
it gives you the good feels seeing like
seeing seeing you guys come together and
raise so much money it was pretty dang
awesome and like you know we're we're a
relic we're relatively new to twitch
we're not a super like we're not super
established streamers and there was a
lot of really big people streaming that
day and I think we we raised we were
ranked like number 18 or 19 yeah of all
the hundreds of people raising money we
like that you guys the community that
came together around us to do good deeds
and to try to help out during a tough
moment for everyone you you guys crushed
it so yeah that's good it's really cool
so for those of you guys who don't know
we have a patreon over at patreon.com
slash Evan and Katelyn we post sneak
peeks of our projects we just like do
little [ __ ] blogs after shows and all
sorts of bonus content over there and
one of the things we did yesterday is
request questions from our supporters
over there so we're just going to kind
of go through some of those our patrons
also like tend to be some of the people
who know us the best and who have
watched a lot of our content and watched
a lot of our past Q&A so there haven't
been there's been really good questions
like not like repeat questions so it's a
really really awesome place to source
questions from yeah and we we may not we
probably won't we won't get all of them
all of them today so we might um spread
it into a couple yeah odd casts but I
figured we would just start going
through some of the ones that we wanted
answer and yeah
starting with Sarah oh no I really got a
reading names that's a challenging one
give it a shot Lee hein
sley Lee line oh well thank you for the
question she asked of all the projects
you have made which ones are most useful
and have been worth it and which ones
have been sitting idle number one that's
so been worth it our desks oh you use
them oh you were thinking of something
else
I had another number one Oh our does a
lot of time we use are the the desk crap
right now of everything that we use
around the house we use the two desks
more than anything and they are really
solid I like a lot of things about each
have we learned things that we can
improve on each oh yes obviously that we
need them to both be much bigger
yeah but also the great thing about how
we constructed these desks they both
have like nice surfaces we can reuse for
whatever and they're two solid aluminum
framing which means we can reconfigure
them and other things in the future or
you know rebuild this desk and do a
version two of it or what have you I
really like to sew so what am i top
projects in terms of like still super
super useful was our garage makeover oh
those are probably the two biggest most
important things I don't think about
like what we do we are at desks or we
are in the garage pick but another top
used project yeah top top in this house
is the catio oh oh yeah all the cat
projects oh yeah he loves the catio we
are also planning on catio part two yeah
I don't know at some point in the future
it could be years are that out right now
yeah but like we are starting to plan it
mm-hmm lightly yeah it's just it's just
we wanted to be a bigger more grand
thing yeah but yeah catty oh she loves I
would say some things so so like there's
some things we make that are kind of
more just to try a technique but like
don't need the thing so for example some
of our resin experiments so like we made
resin planets I'm you know Mike's here
just to see we we kind of just wanted to
try out using these really big sphere
molds with resin yeah we don't do
anything with them they sit in our
garage a lot of our experiments
yeah the potato resin gems yeah you know
um now there are some things that I wish
would get used a little bit more what
about our toast coasters Katelyn are
those things they're still there in our
garage still still an active experiment
they have molded yet even the one with
nothing on it some of our projects
become single holders like the rainbow
bench it's it's just a thing holder now
it's a nice decor item too but yeah I
will say like like a great thing to
build as like a midsize project like a
bench slash coffee table or side table
yes so we have a lot of benches coffee
tables and side tables we got we have
the ripple bench we have the rainbow
bench we have the 2x4 side table we have
the galaxy black coal side table we have
the CNC live edge coffee table we have
the resin geode coffee table you know
one one category of projects that we
have used a lot or all of the home
improvement projects like reorganizing
the closet with those heavy duty shelves
oh I love that yeah it's so great like
anything at all of like like the front
door obviously that we're just kind of
like looking through we're looking
through them yes some things like are
technically in use but it's like it's
not like I couldn't live without them
yeah you know there's a lot of things we
end up not using much like the whole
Wonder Woman cosplay that we started and
never finished yeah but like that I
think the thing that I'm glad that we're
doing is we're not letting that hold us
back from doing things because a lot of
the reason why we do things is to learn
and to grow through the Wonder Woman
cosplay we learned a lot about foam
we've learned thermoplastics yeah
through all of the resin experiments
we've learned
so much right resin which lets us do
cool things like this desk or bigger
things we use like bending resin lamps
those lamps are in use and we learned
that through experimentation and
everything so I think that don't let a
good message to keep in mind is don't
let the practicality of projects hold
you back if you're excited about it just
go for it
learn it get that experience and and
tuck that into your belt and roll roll
that into the next project tuck it in
one project that we've one question
we've gotten a lot that I'm not sure if
we've answered on the podcast let's go
ahead and like put it in record right
now what is the supervisors original
birth name I know you all call her
different things but I'm just curious
Kailyn can tell the story and like this
can sit as a record the full story
Caitlin doesn't have to remember in the
future which podcast relate a question
we get all the time is why do we call
her juba slash Juby is the supervisor
here her real name put it to rest okay
when I when I adopted her um I named her
mochi bear first name mochi middle name
bear because she kind of looked like a
tiny little black bear mm-hm okay I
thought it was kind of like mocha but
cuter sounding I don't know the logic
was like kind of there it's confusing
cuz it's spelled like mochi like the
Japanese ice cream dessert that's not
how you pronounce it but that's not how
you pronounce it it's Caitlin's like
well like the parent that has the weird
name and you know don't say like this
and spell it like this and then that's
yeah yeah no it's exactly that it's like
spelling it's like if we spelled Evan
like a evh aan Avon but yeah so it's
it's a fine name it was too long being
three syllables mochi bear and we still
sometimes call her mochi we call her
mochi like if we're talking about her to
people that don't know
by her you know I don't know it's not
often or like if I go you know her like
vet checkups I say this is moki's
perform will make her or if she's in
trouble
okay no we don't know we don't we go or
turn turn we call her turn Alonzo um
yeah so jube again very convoluted weird
random story jube is a name that my
brother called me once when he was
little and like not me to my face but
there was a photo of me point out and
say jube and call me jube because I was
in a really fluffy dress and that was
just the name that came to his mind I'm
like a big bean yeah I look I did look
kind of like a big a big fluffy like
marshmallow marshmallow marshmallow
marshmallow
I was really fluffy and so somewhere
deep in my brain because this wasn't
long before I adopted her I had it in my
brain that jube is a cute name for
something small and fluffy so I started
calling her jube and you know that
evolved into all the various like
variations Juby juba jookin Juke - bear
- bear yeah I would do bears the
combination of Joe Kenda yeah so there's
all these various things we didn't start
calling her the supervisor until we
started making the channel and it
started I remember what video it was
first mm was it so it started because
when we first started our channel we
didn't have AC in the garage and it was
super super super hot and so um one of
our earlier videos where we did a like
coat rack / key hanger like you know
when we're going to just do this whole
dang thing inside we're gonna set up
drop cloths it is too hot to do it
outside it was horrible it was bad we
would not have this channel we didn't
install AC my gosh yeah no he would but
so anyway so it was the first project we
had done inside for the channel and jube
was very fascinated so she was like
watching us from the couch and I
remember putting in text like a little
thing over her that said supervisor and
then we just started referring to her as
that when she popped up in videos
um and it just kind of became like a
thing now the twitch chat has combined
her name to Juber visor haha how we call
her that as well but yeah so that's like
the very convoluted history of her full
story yeah that's fun um Marcus mono
asks what types of injuries have each
have you gotten directly or indirectly
from making things what were the worst
ones and which ones could have been
totally avoided like I've been falling
through the ceiling I mean that was
probably the worst most most could have
I think all could have been avoided I
have cut myself multiple times by
cutting towards my finger away from me
but I've got I've nicked my finger a few
times yeah you got a little tiny fingers
a lot of little tiny things one one
thing not really related to making I
think we're just decorating our house I
was unpacking a light that we bought
from Ikea and it's a glass circle sphere
and I just bumped it as light as I
possible like on accident against one of
our countertops and it shattered and the
glass hit my toe that was one injury
I've had recently so probably one of my
worst ones and mine are mine aren't that
bad mine don't really involve blood it
wasn't it was in the workshop but it
wasn't related to a specific project we
were just kind of cleaning up but I
dropped a 2x4 on my toes yeah I thought
it broke it didn't but like I couldn't
move it it was really swollen 2x4 it
wasn't even that fall I don't know what
happened it must have hit it like just
right on the corner
yeah and that was I mean I guess I could
have been wearing steel-toed boots just
to clean up in general we are very
conscious of safety from my engineering
background I came from a background
where safety is super super super
important we have meetings before we do
things and it's like that's has been
drilled into my head and I know how
dangerous a lot of this is in our videos
we come across as silly and fun and we
are silly and fun but at the same time
before we do thing this Kate and I
usually check in with each other and say
okay I'm gonna be here you're gonna be
here we're gonna move like this we like
like if it's a test if it's like a big
cut we like make sure everything is
braced and we like test it to make sure
that it but we just don't capture all
interesting something with fire we have
a fire extinguisher nearby yeah you know
there's there's lots of various things
yeah but that does make it into the
video so much because it's the silly
things that are more fun yeah let's see
yeah I've been following through this
you know that probably was the that was
a scariest nose the accident that had
the highest chance of serious serious
injuries that is scary addicts are just
scary in general you are pretty bruised
up on your back and your legs feet
probably was before that but we've been
we've been pretty lucky like nothing
major or life-changing yeah yeah I don't
think so I did kind of not too bad but
making the UM the cat treat toys before
gee oh yeah when it's loud the drill
slap you yeah when the drill slapped me
yeah it didn't like I don't think that
drill slaps make a bar and draw and ask
sometimes Caitlin wears glasses and
sometimes not is there a time replace
when you always need them are you
farsighted or nearsighted to use contact
lenses okay so we each have I stories
that's true yeah um different it's just
you don't wear your glasses super often
sometimes in videos you wear them ah so
so so MA my eyes are confusing one of my
eyes is nearsighted one of them is
farsighted I actually have perfect
vision I can see very detailed I'm
looking at the mic that's like in front
of my face and I can see it really well
with my nearsighted I with my farsighted
eye I can read way over there my brain
just has acclimated to it and I
I'm like it's strange when I put on
glasses and both of my eyes have far
sight again
well I get headaches I get dizzy
sometimes which is why I usually don't
wear them because I have perfect bifocal
vision built-in like I don't like the
thing is as I age like like how you
focus yes because how you focus your
eyes is there's a muscle in your head
and in your eye socket and everything
that pulls and contracts and and and and
shifts and everything and as you age
that gets weaker when you're younger you
can see far and near because your
muscles are really good and as you age
that muscle ages and you aren't able to
focus as much it's more of like a fixed
lens and you can only see at like one
focus range that your eye is naturally
shaped for so as I age my farsighted eye
is gonna become more farsighted and my
near side of that is going to become
more nearsighted so I'll be able to use
one eye for close-in one eye for far so
it's different for me um I had to get
glasses starting in like fourth or fifth
grade and I had them all the way up till
iowa's 21 and I got LASIK surgery which
was great and it lasted for many many
years but one thing that I didn't know
when I got it is that it eventually kind
of starts degrading and so I am now when
we started out when we started the
channel I was okay at this point three
years later I have gone to a shift where
my eyes have started reverting they're
not nearly as bad as they were for most
of my life where I couldn't see more
than a couple feet in front of my face
but they're bad enough that like with
all my glasses I can't read the labels
on anything in our closet or like the
text on my computer which is so it's
like your eyes your eyesight is very
usable it's just like far away details
aren't the best so yeah so often times
for like when we're streaming Caitlin
needs to read the text on the screens
that's really really tiny or
so I the reason I wear my glasses more
on stream and actually because I don't
feel like putting on like as much makeup
as I do for filming and I'm like AUB's
through my glasses fanciness to your
face yeah add some fanciness some
symmetry the computer's close enough
that I can read it decently most of the
time sometimes extra small things I do
have to go in a little bit closer yeah
but yeah so I hated having contacts I
don't think I would go back to contacts
as like a like regular measure and
sometimes I'll be wearing my glasses and
sometimes they won't be is this kind of
random
alright will Burke asks Evan how did the
coding for the poster project feel it's
a completely different skill set
compared a lot of other recent project
tasks I in general like coding it's fun
to problem-solve it's fun to do that I
took robotics classes in in college
while studying engineering as an
elective and I really liked it
one like so on that side of thing this
is actually like doing of it and
learning of it I like doing that I like
learning it but what
Kaitlin and I do our business is
creating content and I just haven't seen
any examples of people creating widely
accessible code in content that is
entertaining and desired by people to
watch so you say coding content you mean
like instructional instructional code
and content or like I think that
demonstrating what code does is
interesting like demonstrating the end
result of my work in the poster project
was was interesting and was was pretty
neat but like the actual process of
coding for me at least involves googling
a whole bunch researching codes and
libraries looking at example codes pull
in snippets from here to there to there
to there testing it out it fails testing
like tweaks out it fails lots and lots
of failures loss and ha tons of
iterations
I probably exported code a hundred times
during this prod
and like that just that many repeated
failures and tests just at least for my
level it's just it's just not I just
don't see making good content and that's
okay if we had time but you know we just
haven't had that much time so it was
interesting I'm glad I did it I'm gonna
keep on doing it but I think that like
me learning code it's gonna kind of be a
side hobby and when I integrate it into
project school and if we wait we have a
desired outcome that coding can solve
coding and electronics and solve then
I'll pursue it actively for a while and
and integrate the results but I think in
terms of the like build there's like a
range from interesting to less
interesting like resin is always
interesting which is why we do it a lot
because it's so unknown it's like so
fluid it's artistic it's satisfying and
like like we've done resin pores like 20
times on this channel not always like
it's not always the primary focus but
we've done Sony resin things and it's so
different interesting unique and
unexpected every time like woodworking
is kind of in the middle some aspects of
woodworking is interesting coding is on
the far end of not interesting from my
perspective like this in general we make
videos that we would want to watch and I
know coding might be interesting for
some people but watch and other people
code may not be the most interesting to
me and that's what we know so we make
the content that we would like to watch
and that's how we judge all of this so
not saying that code incontinent isn't
interesting in general but for the type
of content we like to make it's kind of
there's another question from will kind
of related to what you're just talking
about Kaitlin what's something you would
love to make using resin but is probably
highly impossible for safety slash
structural reasons um we do have a resin
table that's on our list it's not really
impossible for like safe for like
structural reasons like it would be
sturdy yeah the problem is it would
weigh hundreds of pounds so that's an
issue because it's essentially a solid
block of resin yeah their materials um
like like ten pound and gallons of resin
or something in like a single piece
maybe more um this is not fully related
but there have been some resin projects
and some we've kind of done anyway just
looks like caveats
but resin isn't food safe but like yeah
that's often something where it's like
oh man that would be so cool to make it
out of resin yeah
like it'd be so fun to make like a resin
coffee cup or something but there's a
lot of stuff that you know you can't you
should really be like eating or drinking
out of resin last question from will
Burke have you ever thought about
completely swapping tasks for one
project to mix it up
in general we both can do a lot of what
the other person does we like
overlapping our skills and and stuff but
we also really like efficiency I think
is so important to us yeah efficiency
always wins in the end so I don't
foresee us I don't foresee as being like
hey Kalin how about you learn CAD right
now just you know even though in theory
it'd be great for me to become more
proficient at CAD and it would be great
for like you to you know do more of a
graphics like graphic design or
something you know and nobody but even
like especially I feel like there's more
things that like Evan does that I can't
do than I do that you know know what we
can what do we do well like what's the
main thing we do make videos yeah you
need to edit for that oh no no like I I
halfway at it that's I would like I'll
do like the difference between Wyatt and
Kayla nod 50% of it Kailyn like gets it
pretty close to a hundred percent and
also she like wall she edits she's done
it
so many times she knows like as she like
drags content and she knows like the
flow of things she knows when to go fast
when to go slower
she knows what what music to put in and
everything and that's just something I'd
struggle with and I feel frustrated and
I would go very slow like would it in
general potentially be good I don't know
I don't know how I'm not sure like in
some ways maybe I could help out if you
are you know not available or you need
you need a break or or something but
let's just like structure our schedule
and life and everything so that what
neither one of us is completely
overwhelmed we can balance each other
out but in general no we haven't really
concerned if there is something that
like if there's a specific task where it
would make the video more entertaining I
could see us doing something like that I
can't think of the best example but like
let's say the this this example
obviously doesn't apply to us but let's
say Evan was really great at soap making
and I sucked and I was really great at
candle making and he sucked yeah and we
kind of like instructed each other to do
the other task but something where it's
like the process is entertaining but
like me trying to learn CAD is not
entertaining to watch so and if it's not
entertaining to watch then of course
there is value in learning things we
don't have the time you know one very
interesting thing about both of the
skills that we're talking about the main
things that we don't overlap because in
terms of writing social media post
uploading social media posts negotiating
with sponsors uploading the gaming
videos doing the metadata for that like
so much of what we do in our days
there's complete overlap either one of
us can do it and that is the stuff we
flex on when when I'm busy with CAD
Caitlin does all of that when Kayla's
busy was editing I try to do all of that
and so there's a ton of flexibility that
in our days because in terms of our days
filming together we do together always
because like you know it's better
together or if even just one of us is on
well you know being
shown the other one of us is filming or
monitoring or etc so that's what we
spend a lot of our time doing but
between like while we're not filming
more time is spent doing all the
miscellaneous stuff than even editing
which is our second biggest time sock
yeah
so we are flexible and so much of what
we do and we can swap there but and it's
interesting in terms of the two skills
that we've been talking about CAD and
editing they take a very specific like
mindset and skill that can't really be
taught easily with CAD I could show
Caitlin like all the buttons to click
and everything like that but I have a
specific knack for visualizing 3d
objects in my head I just see them in my
head I see 3d objects all the time I
look at things I see the internals of
how they work like in my hat I always
have like x-ray vision but just like of
like the components and stuff I like I
love looking at mechanical things and
breaking down how they work that's just
how my mind works it's always been how
my mind work whereas my mind I edit
things in my brain okay when we're
filming I'm like oh I'm Evan just did
something silly I'm gonna cut to my face
here because I like know I'm doing
something like in reaction yeah you know
or whatever it is or like this is where
I cut the music
in my head there's just some like
natural inherent boost that we both have
for those two things that like we might
be able to get there through thousands
of hours of practice perhaps like we
love editing oh I don't go yes that's
great yeah okay next question so this is
from Gary Chris well but we also had a
similar question from Corey van note who
is one non maker youtuber that you would
like to collab with yeah Corey just was
talking about collabs in general but I
thought that Gary is like twist on it a
non maker you okay do you have yours in
mind yeah okay so I have mine in mine -
it's all explained why I
think that it's like who you want to
collab with or just people we want to
like hang out with yeah there's so many
cool people out there making YouTube
videos that I just wanna hang out with
one one I have like a specific scenario
even for my oh one couple that we want
to hang out with it makes YouTube videos
is Jenna and Julian just because they're
you seem like so much fun I was making
part with them I want you own into art
art in five minutes I was like a hangout
yeah that sounds fun I would like to do
like a resin poor person oh my gosh I'm
not it's very acrylic poor adjacent
which they've done it's so funny because
like if you watched in and Julian you
know that that Julian is like the Aries
he's a little bit chaotic and everything
but it's funny because when they do art
he kind of has a easier time stopping at
a good point and everything we're Jenna
just like keeps on going she's got that
too much Dean and I relates to the too
much dream I just want to keep on having
stuff yeah that would be super super fun
yeah all right so let's see the Brian
Fitzpatrick asks I love the variety of
projects you guys make even when it
pains you not put resin on everything
which project do you think that the
lowest barrier entry cost experience etc
and which had the highest so I think in
general um projects that have lower
barriers to entry honestly it my first
instinct um well I mean let me back it
up I think like anything that's a little
bit more on the crafty side and doesn't
require like pure tools because power
tools can be expensive and they can be
kind of intimidating and like it's a
little bit hard if you don't have the
space so staying on the crafty side
doing things like little IKEA hacks or
things that are more art based but for
the sake of this I think our akhir hack
was our most accessible video we've ever
done yeah if we were going to choose a
single video I think that Kia acts so
but I'll go into like kind of one one
step further
projects um I actually think that
concrete projects really alright we are
pretty darn low barrier to entry I
wanted to say like woodworking I think
that : projects are good bang for your
buck but they still are hard but see I
think like I think it's really I think
it's a lot easier to learn like making
no no I do not say mold making yeah
there's a lot of concrete stuff you can
do without mold making there's like a
little simple hacks like the the
concrete's tools and stuff like concrete
buckets tool like one of our first
project is we just made these little
concrete letters doing using
store-bought molds concrete coasters
using store-bought molds there's a lot
of concrete stuff or even if you're
setting up like slightly bigger things
there's a lot of really easy molds you
can make she's using wood what about low
acrylics yeah but that goes into my
first category of like art or art and
crafts okay so if you're excluding arts
and crafts excluding arts and crafts I
actually think that concrete can be one
of the lowest barrier to entry because
it's very cheap yeah there's not that
many variables you know with woodworking
there's so many more variables the type
of wood the level of tool you have and
concrete is more foolproof than resin
it's Anna's cheaper way cheaper which
makes it a lower barrier energy concrete
yeah and you can just like get it at the
store near you well I guess presently
you can get concrete and crafts that's
on the easier side I have one in
particular for the hardest okay what was
yours I didn't think of one in
particular I have like a hard category
let's see leave my category lines yeah I
I think digital fabrication based ones
and I would say specifically CNC
specifically seems to be our big barrier
to entry need to know CAD you need to
know programming yeah like if you if you
go with the complex ones you can just
like open up easel draw shapes draw
letters and it just cuts and there can
be that's pretty easy I like still
expensive but it could it can be easy if
you go for the easy ones yeah I have
something even harder when I first
thought of like our hardest project
we've done
I actually thought of the randomized
poster that
of cast son of experiments with like
like materials and everything
it required electronics it required like
wiring and programming and a whole bunch
of C and C and all that and I thought
that was gonna be our hardest but I
actually have one step up from that
Damascus knife oh gosh ha ha ha you need
a lot of equipment a lot of experience a
lot of barriers entry to make Damascus
yeah ok that one wins by far if we
hadn't have had Alek then no way we
would ever ever ever made that and all
of his machines and equipment and stuff
yeah ok so that was different for us
because we did do it with Alec at his
shop with all of his stuff but it was a
project that we took on yes one one
project that like um I actually think
was decently those more difficult than I
expected was actually our resin geode
table to me Oh
flattening the slab it wasn't like it
was time-consuming and annoying but it
wasn't like the most difficult thing
because we all you could have done is we
could have just dropped it off at a
woodworking place and paid the money and
they could have just given yeah yeah I
think Damascus wins Damascus went from
alright so Tony yang or Tony Tang asks
when you guys started the channel was
hard to motivate yourself to shoot and
edit the videos I shot a bunch of videos
and never actually found the time to
edit any of them it was very easy to
motivate ourselves to shoot and edit the
videos because that was the whole like
we knew why we knew why we were doing it
and we were very driven to accomplish
those goals if you don't I think it's
easy to like lose steam if you don't
really have a vision for the brand for
the business for the channel for just
all of that because it's what we do is
fun what we do is
enjoyable for us but it's not easy it
takes a lot of time and it's draining
yeah and I feel like um I feel like like
you see so many people putting the stuff
that they make on YouTube and so it's
like well that seems like the obvious
natural progression like maybe you start
sharing it on Instagram first then it
seems like the not the next step would
be YouTube but if you start doing that
without really knowing why then I think
that's like you said that's where you
lose your motivation yeah ask them like
the motivation wasn't because it wasn't
really about having a YouTube channel it
was about finding a way that we could
work together doing things that we liked
and YouTube was kind of like the the
path to that goal and also I mean
there's the there's the saying that I
don't like in a way you know from
Silicon Valley and stuff like fail hard
fail fast like if like you know like if
you're gonna put a lot of time and money
and effort into this thing like starting
a business takes a lot of time money
effort all this stuff you know we
started with fairly basic equipment but
like by now where we're at right now we
have spent so much money on all of this
the computers the cameras the the sound
equipment the supply is the streaming
all of that if you're getting into this
seriously you're gonna spend a lot of
money so we spent the least amount of
money needed to get going and then we
tried to like hey let's pretend like
this is our full-time job so that we
know if we should keep on going down
this route and let's do it as fast and
as hard as we can so that we know
whether we like this or not let's
pretend to like that's basically like
our our mentality was let's pretend like
we're full-time youtubers right now even
though we are both working jobs yeah
that's that's that's how we went into it
and I think another thing and this isn't
that worked for us it might maybe it's
like too much pressure but it worked for
us is we gave ourselves a launch day
yeah for our channel and we gave
ourselves like
few months to film a handful of videos
and kind of get started and get a feel
for things but then we stuck to that
date and I think we don't have a date
then there's nothing holding you to it
and it makes it easier to put it off and
put it off and yeah yeah um second to
last question
Joel cannon asks what is one skill or
lesson you wish you had learned sooner I
think that when I think of everything
that we've learned I mainly think of
what we like what we're actually doing
yes we're building the stuff but the
main thing we're putting most of our
time and to is creating content so when
I actually think of what lessons do we
wish we had to learn sooner all of the
thoughts I have go to content creation
and not actually woodworking resin any
of that stuff because also those lessons
we learned we learned on camera and
there's good that we learn them on
camera cause it made for good content
the main thing I wish we had have
learned earlier is how to film and edit
efficiently and we've talked about this
I think a lot in past episodes I think
when we interviewed you about editing in
general but like learning how to do
interest how to do outros learning how
to you know win the film and how long
the film and then what style to film and
like all of those things we've learned
about like it actually all comes down to
filming for me I think a lot of it does
for me too and then and this isn't
really like a skill set but more just
like coming to a realization that the
investment was worth it but investing in
better audio and better cameras like we
finally did that in 2019 but we started
the channel in 2017 we're dealing with
really bad audio oh I'm like okay
cameras like the end product look good
but they were really hard to deal with
and they're hard to film with hard to
film with never focusing right ah
so there we went through so much pain on
the audio and video unnecessarily
unnecessarily yeah we should have just
invested in that earlier yeah but
and it kind of goes back to what you're
saying before we wanted to like figure
out if this is the path we wanted to go
on yeah before like investing we just
have to start running yeah yeah we just
have to start running with what we had
and then you kind of like you're like
well it's good enough this is what we've
been using and you kind of put it off
another thing I wish I had if we had
have learned earlier this is the most
complicated thing of everything of all
of the I think skills that we've learned
like win the film you can describe that
you can teach that when to and like you
know camera gear you can tell someone
what to get and everything the most
difficult skill we've picked up on is an
intuitive sense of what will make for a
good clickable video yeah and I think
that's the holy grail of what like
youtubers are always pursuing not that
we know it better at it now than we used
to be when we know it we have a pretty
good like yeah feeling we like coming up
with those ideas is painful difficult
hard time-consuming not always pleasant
we go through days when you're under the
gun and you need a video project and
you're losing days then it's hard if
you're just discussing ideas over coffee
over at show morning that's that's
amazing a fun
well like coming up with ideas is really
hard but like knowing when you have it
mm-hmm I think that's the thing like
we've gotten so much better about and
knowing when we don't have it and we
need to keep on pushing yeah yeah I was
trying to think of like other kind of
behind the scenes skills I feel like we
actually on the business side of things
in terms of like talking with sponsors
and this and that I feel like we did
pretty well early on just kind of like
because of our past business experience
we both worked at large corporations and
we know what corporations want and and
stuff to a certain degree and we know
how to talk with them and in terms of
things like like video style you know
we've shifted our style earlier it might
have been too forced or whatever so
there's a certain amount of like I don't
want to change you know I wouldn't wish
for things to be different because I
like
where I am now and if things have been
different we might not be where we are
now I think that if I were to say like
one skill I wish I'd have learned sooner
if we could only choose one I might
choose knowing what videos are good yeah
because more than anything I think that
would benefit us yeah because if from
the beginning we had have known how to
choose those more like clickable videos
we would be even bigger than we are now
not that that's the point I mean the
point is to hang out together and have
fun but a lot of what we're talking
about is like for the benefit of the
business and the bigger the channel is
the bigger the businesses so yeah that's
my thoughts last question from Sara
Launer
I don't see an end at all Sara flour
flour what does the perfect day off look
like okay I want to hear your I have I
have two answers okay I don't hear yours
first okay so not waking up to too early
have we make really good coffee at home
probably having some coffee just like
chillin on the couch chatting um then we
would go to brunch yeah and have tasty
brunch and think of that past the pasta
oh yeah oh yeah good so we run CH and
then um I don't know the exact order of
things there definitely be like massages
like I want to go gosh is and like
commandeer someone's hot tub maybe it's
at the place we get massages
maybe we borrow your parents hot tub I
just want to like be in a hot tub and
then like just just relax I'm just like
just like float there read read yeah
read chill by the pool slash hot tub um
and then like have a good dinner and
watch a movie or something and then
going to walk that would be my I I have
two categories that would be my ideal
normal day off yeah and then my dream
day off we would be in Krabi Thailand oh
well yeah we would be at this this one
resort that we have
lutely love where we went on our
honeymoon we'd be there and would just
have like another day like we had on our
honeymoon just like being at the beach
traveling around going on a hike going
out on a boat to a picnic lunch on an
island like this like like a vacation
like living that vacation life that'd be
my ideal day off that's a little bit of
a that's a very big amount of a stretch
but like if it's almost asking me what
my ideal day is that that'd be my ideal
day I think that's a great place to end
it um thank you everyone who submitted
questions we'll try to do this again in
the future and just keep on ass
answering your questions this is really
fun oh yeah well wrapping up the QA
and then we're doing Q of the week or
sing of the week and I'm gonna quickly
look at my phone because I have
forgotten
okay um so my thing of the week it's not
a specific video and I'm gonna try to
give like a like a Content thing because
I know a lot of people are looking for
like extra stuff to watch and a lot of
you guys have probably already heard of
this cuz it's not like it's a small
thing but um buon appetito know you're
gonna take my thing Bon Appetit has been
doing this like at home series and it's
really cute really well put together
it's like all your favorite characters
from bone Appetit in their home kitchens
and it's filmed where it kind of cuts
back and forth between them and so there
will be a theme like making their
favorite coffee or making pantry pasta
so cute and wholesome you're gonna see
their pets and their kitchens and like
their kids and it's just really cute
really wholesome like you kind of just
feel like you're hanging out with them
yeah it's awesome there's several in the
series and that's my thing of the week
did I talk long enough for you to find a
week okay okay this is this is gonna be
completely random because it's just kind
of coming out of nowhere yes yes yes
okay
so Kaitlin and I also run a gaming
channel called evident Kaelyn gaming you
might have heard us talk about it a few
times so we I have every now and then
will watch like another person's gaming
video just to see what other people are
doing and stuff like that and a lot of
them are fairly typical well you kind of
expect from gaming videos except for
this one channel neebs gaming what the
heck I've never seen more cinematically
edited gaming videos that are also so
hilarious and like immersive they're
like a TV episode they're very
interesting they're very unique so so
like they usually wrap around a plot
which is good all of these games they
also have a person also they're just
being a camera person not doing anything
just feel like you know like they have a
three print like they have three main
characters and then usually like a
camera guy who's another player in the
game that is just watching the other
characters so that there's a camera
quote-unquote view of what the three
people are doing and they do like
establishing shots or like they do like
sunrise or sunset or like a shot of
their base a shot of the race on the
outside and they're like oh and one
scene one of them was being pulled under
water and like they had the underwater
voice of factum like it's so it's just
so well done but they're all so well
done it's not just that but they're also
hilarious but like the unique thing is
like how well done it is cuz it yeah it
makes it like a show with your tablet
shots in the third-person view
and like is great that's great it's so
great a lot of I don't want this a lot
of like gaming videos are not heavily
edited the typical gaming video is the
game and calm like commentary sometimes
with the face cam sometimes without a
face cam and usually it's just
highlights all of the funny moments
highlights as in like the dead parts cut
out the dead parts cut out and usually
it's just like all of the funny things
that happened during the gameplay that's
the standard thing but this there's like
a goal and then there they get
sidetracked and then they have this
quest and then like there's like it's
interesting they also do something okay
so this is similar to what I do and this
is maybe just something but like my
brain thinks of because I am always in
editing mode but when you are adding
music to your video there's like there's
there's music because it's cool and
trendy and then there's like music to
make the you the viewer feel a certain
way so when we first started editing we
did music that was cool and trendy just
stuff that we thought sounded cool had
nothing to do with the video now the way
I use music is like if there's a tense
music I will use tense music if
something messes up I'm gonna use like
derpy music or sad or sad music or
whatever and this helps like emphasize
moments yeah if we're just kind of like
being goofy I'll put some like slightly
goofy music in the background and so
it's not about choosing something that's
nice to listen to it's about choosing
something that emphasizes the mood
appropriate and I haven't seen other
gaming channels do that our editors do
it in the gaming channel yeah and you
know it's a lot of the same music we use
on our main channel but they do it on
their gaming channel really well and
they use a lot of same songs and I was
like oh that's a Kevin MacLeod's
investigation it's fun it's fun yeah all
right guys well I hope you enjoyed this
Q&A episode I hope you're all are doing
ok out there we definitely want to
answer more of the cues that we couldn't
get to yeah because you guys have a lot
of good questions yeah and if you want
to support Evan in Caitlyn podcast you
know share with a friend perhaps rate of
five stars we really appreciate it we
see every single five star review it
comes to our email inbox and it's just
like a little nice boost to our day so
we appreciate it and we'll afford to see
you in the next one
[Music]